hey guys welcome back to the last
episode of season three what a year it
has been so many Lads so many great
Yarns it's been awesome being able to
share the Journey of some of these
Champion lairs with you all and a
massive thank you to you guys for tuning
in I'm not exactly sure what season four
is going to look like but I can assure
you that what a lad will be continuing
in some form also a massive thank you to
all the sponsors for the season it has
kept this podcast going and if you do
want to support the podcast for maybe
season four then please get in touch
there's plenty of ways you can support
the podcast so reach out and we can make
something work speaking of sponsors it's
been awesome to have Hayden from eqs
sponsor the podcast now many suggest
this lad as the best registered quantity
server on the planet so if you're
looking to build renovate your existing
home or looking at a commercial
development look no further than Hayden
eqs is based in Palmerston North but
they work throughout New Zealand they
can can provide estimates from concept
plans through to the final designs so if
you're interested please contact Hayden
and all the information to get in touch
with him is below speaking of lads Tammy
Bateman from ostudio now he is such a
good lad that he's even got an early
Christmas present for you all have a
listen to this Jimmy Tim Bateman here
from o Studio mate it's great seeing you
around the studio getting involved so
we've decided to give your listeners
another promo code to give it a crack
too all they need to do is enter
Waterland class all in capitals and no
spaces when purchasing a drop in class
which is yoga or pilates at the checkout
online to get 100 off the class yep
that's a free class as always if anyone
is interested in opening your own o
Studio around New Zealand or abroad get
in touch at
ostudio.co.nz forward slash lad we'd
love to hear from you the next o studio
in rolleston is opening in early 2023
which is super exciting and we're
currently looking at other local
locations around New Zealand too all the
best and back to the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh what a lab well just like that we've
come to the end of season three and as
always I try and finish the season on a
high with one of the best Lads possible
and for this one I've got him the gifted
singer actor rugby player and coach has
done it all in his eventful career today
which has seen him play for the
Hurricanes the Highlanders the blues
Rebels Wellington Lions otago Rico black
Rams New Zealand Maltese Junior All
Blacks New Zealand Sevens and of course
the mighty all blacks and since becoming
a coach he's guided the Crusaders to two
titles and the Wellington lines to one
and on top of all that he's a father of
soon to be six and a massive massive lad
he is one of the greats that is the one
and only tomity Alison welcome bro hey
Kilda thanks for having me on mate I
reckon that's my biggest intro yet mate
you've done it all and I didn't even
mention your Jujitsu
yeah uh yeah that wouldn't be a very
long list
it has to be cool be very lucky up to
the stage for sure no and how did you
get into Jitsu because you're coaching
it well at the moment I'm unsure when I
when I first started
um and and I haven't done a lot but I've
I've done enough I think for to be able
to put it into footy yeah
um Talk probably towards the end of my
career I just enjoyed doing something
other than weights but you come to
understand it's an it's a great sport my
kids all started rolling when we were
living in Melbourne they were there with
Ben hall and then also we're access Jiu
Jitsu and um in Tokyo as well so true
that's a great sport yeah mate it does
cross over well and you do coach it
Wella but
um obviously you're getting the Reps in
at the moment yeah yeah um again I think
a lot of things you we assume that the
players understand certain things and
um to get in and feel a few uh
especially with the tackling and the
Collision stuff is
um you think about a jiu jitsu black
belt or or an instructor
he's not actually just walking around
he's he's good enough to be hold that
belt and he gets around and rolls as
um as he teaches and I I've always liked
that as a coaching method especially as
a young coach to be able to still feel a
few and speaking of coaching is just off
the back of it and very successful
season with Wellington guiding them to
not only the championship but also the
ram Philly Shield what was that year
like for you it was good it was a really
enjoyable I think we keep it really
simple we try to focus more about
ourselves our footy and our journey and
regardless of the results I think we did
that part well
and then the results followed so I
really enjoyed it we had a good group
with some with some leaders some All
Blacks that were were back with us for
that period and they were motivated so
it's it's always
um
it's easier when you you're good players
want to continue to be great and
everyone else follows so it was cool it
was really enjoyable year had some young
boys coming through you know like young
Peter Lark ideas
Riley Higgins and 20s boys that are
coming through and will be good for the
area and obviously you speak about that
experience guys like TJ and really
important positions Jacksonville massive
roles for you guys that yeah yeah they
were and we probably put a little bit
more pressure on them this year than in
the past and
and the thing with TJ zetty
um he thrives off that challenge and and
I think it made his leadership uh better
and and having him in the group
um because of the standards that you
know we asked in the standards that he
he likes to sit the rest were forced to
follow so
um the same with the bus Jules has been
awesome he's been back
um three years now and again having a
true profession who's done it all in the
environment is just great so having for
those guys especially you can't really
put a price on a day that that
leadership and that experience people
often talk about it but you don't really
understand how important it is until you
see it out there yeah yeah I keep
telling my coaches
got let go
um and for when you're from the area you
know Jules are Strathmore boy and and um
Teigen Jacko a porir boy so that uh you
know from the area they play Club footy
there
um so they it's easy for them to care so
the the experience as well as
um you know I want to lift the Jersey is
you know it was good great combination
and now you're down here in Christchurch
about to go into your third Super Rugby
campaign
um you obviously move down without your
family though so how hard is that
um you have to ask my wife easy for you
yeah I'm just Netflix after training no
it's it's a choice you know we we make
sure we discuss it and and try and work
out what's best for
um the whanau like murderous boys start
at St Pat's town this year and we want
to make sure we had enough support there
on the ground we both said to
grandparents and you know Maori
Polynesian family so we're really tight
anyway but you just wanted the the
habits and to be as consistent for the
kids
um as possible and
um yeah another baby on the way so yeah
yeah it's definitely just me down here
uh but this there's plenty of work
anyway so you finish your days you just
keep keep plowing and making sure you're
you're prepping and therefore the times
I get to go home I'm home you know
getting better at that balance Matt your
wife must be an absolute Champion hey
like it's not just one one two kids it's
five kids and one on the way so pregnant
with five other kids to to look after
it's a it's a hell of a job yeah yeah
now she does
um a great job and yeah it's it's one of
those ones you know like in in the
business that we're in with footy you
get accolades and you get people uh pets
on the back and jerseys to hang but
we're probably in society under
underappreciate the the hard work that
goes on literally behind the scenes at
home and and how consistent and that's
real no days off uh hashtag you know
so yeah she's a superstar rod and yeah
she wanted another one and
you delivered another one
is that you dance sex surely or it was
me done at five
um
but I'm yeah grateful
yeah
um no it's it's again it reshapes you
you know and you you change what your
year might look like but for the better
so that's cool we're looking forward to
it does it get easier once life changing
really isn't it and then two you know
they all look I'm at three but they've
all sort of got a little bit easier but
they've had their patches I I think we
understand his parents you know like
um you get your first kid and it's
everything's organic and like
she wanted me to literally grow
strawberries you know I haven't really
got much of that school as you would
have seen like most actors don't grow
strawberries and
um to now you know like did you eaten
plastic off the floor so yeah uh you
definitely grow your
um your rules that's so true though and
sleep and all those things though first
one you're so structured trying to nail
it but yeah it doesn't really work yeah
it's cool though like that they
definitely look up to their older
brothers and sisters and I try to change
my um my baby the other one time this
year she's three and see if you want to
handle their pajamas and she's like
looking at me like yeah she yeah took
them off went in the bathroom showed
herself changed self brushing her teeth
stuck a toothbrush on the Murray
don't even mouthwashed like while she's
butting up her [ __ ] still looking at me
yeah it's kind of like whoa I need to
get my three-year-old around to your
house which is training you know and if
again if you're forced to if you don't
have that many hands
um because my oldest son loves
PlayStation so he hasn't been helping my
hope so they're just forced to you know
and yeah it's cool though yeah and you
mentioned you're um acting and your
childhood acting stage so we'll go there
what obviously growing up
um not everyone grows up as a famous
child actor but what was your childhood
like uh yeah so it was me Macaulay
Culkin and Drew anemia from um uh New
Zealand's Got Talent
nah it's it was quite cool like to have
a look at that industry
um when did you decide to get into it
like I wasn't I didn't I think Mum and
Dad ran out of money and they needed
some
Maori kids uh in um I think it's called
coat hanger at the local management
agency so
um my brother and I went there and uh
you know that was probably in the dollar
hack of days and
um yeah we ripped in and
um you've got a few roles and they were
cool you know like well paid and yeah
but I realized pretty quick I had the
patience to wait all day for your
one minute part then wait all day again
but I realized
pretty early that it wasn't going to be
for me like uh like I do enough acting
as it is I don't actually need a
and I like my own characters are you
kind of yeah when you're doing that
you're having a be someone else's and be
the way they think it should be so
um yeah but it was as I said it was a
cool experience and cool to have a look
at it yeah what age were you when you
first went out
um I think they caught me at nine
um yeah were you nine when you did that
did that ad uh ten I think true oh yeah
you look younger yeah um probably just
good skincare yeah um yeah no celebrity
Wheel of Fortune it peaked That
Celebrity Wheel of Fortune what was that
role
um spinning the wheel I think I was on
with Frank Bunce and Nick from shortland
Street
um but I knew once I had celebrity Wheel
of Fortune that
um that was probably going to be the
peak
and then what was it like doing that ad
obviously uh you're pretty famous for
that stand by me we always a singer we
comfortable singing in front of a camera
with all blacks watching what was the
setup my point of difference was my
dancing oh yeah so that's probably what
got me over the line and when we went to
the studio to record the singing like I
think the music I was like man
um
so that was a big old day of auto tune
and
um I hope it was my voice
but yeah yeah so yeah funny how that
works but uh
no I just it was cool like
back then with the all black secret
you're you're a fan
maybe not in the way you're a fan now
you know like I saw them in kind of
buzzing you're a kid and like Fame and
notoriety whatever's just probably
changed the wee bit nowadays
um
but at the time it was cool it was cool
to meet meet all those guys and you know
it must have been like confident ass kid
to be able to get up there
um in front of TV cameras and sing like
me at that age I couldn't think of
anything worse you know even like
speeches in front of your class but like
a nightmare but yeah you obviously had
that confidence in you I we I think we
were trained like um
I went to
um
was one of my teachers and he was he was
a singer yeah actor so south side of
Bombay what's the time Mr Wolf so we we
would do a lot of ficordital and a lot
of people and preparing as kids and when
you're young and you just feel like
well that's what everyone's doing we
should go around the classroom you know
manga our ewe and you're doing that
often you're having karaoke so you're
standing up and leading and speaking if
I caught it or same thing uh so
potential was just training and so when
you stood up in other places that you
didn't really think about it I'm like
anyone like in front of a big crowd or a
wrong crowd I don't really know what I'm
doing or I'm making up the D stuff you
get a wee bit nervous uh but I think
that's probably where it come from yeah
would you be confident to do it now more
confident now than when you were like
would you sing Stand By Me Oh man
um
nah
because you have been doing singing
lessons hey like you you do have a good
voice now probably better than you did
when you were at that age yeah it's
interesting because I'm running out of
tricks for Ray and I've been doing
karaoke like sit-ups in the morning
picking the energy going and he said
Friday's a big one so
um I better make sure I know
the lyrics for that and I can um
they hopefully like Shaggy bombastic or
something
is it called baritone what would like
Davido would know
so when did you decide that acting
wasn't you you said it you didn't quite
feel like uh it was what you wanted to
do did you have a option to pursue it
um you do because you you kind of I
don't know what they call it what the
agency kind of go and
always take classes or take new pictures
and I don't think my teenage years were
good to me you know with the acne so
that's pretty pretty limiting
um appreciate my wife for
for trusting that I'd get through it
in the early days is it literally how it
dried up did you feel did you feel like
pressure from it
no I don't and no definitely not it was
uh now I just I didn't do it for a few
years and yeah kind of got sick of it
after a while yeah and was rugby always
like another dream of yours was it was
that always the girl no no that wasn't
either
um I enjoyed playing
um it's as much the next person if you
make a rip team when you're younger
again it's
it's cool I don't really probably
towards the end of college like when
you're in college and I went to Manor
College a small school
um same as TJ and we were like in the
third division and
um you know we had limited numbers and
stuff so I reckon probably towards the
end of my last year at College I was
like oh
I'm gonna give this a good crack once I
leave so Club rugby through North helped
me in that first year to yes start
having a decent going
I played for New Zealand under 19s the
year after that so I was young coming
out of school
and I think once I made a New Zealand
site that was my first New Zealand site
because I hadn't played Wellington
Secondary School reps or anything like
that sure I kind of worked out I worked
really hard for a good year and a bit
just for myself and I made in that side
and I was kind of like oh man a bit of
an aha moment where the card it helps
yeah
yeah so what was that flick of the
switch that made you think should I'm
going to give this a go you know I I
honestly like looking back now I feel
because of our fish with Dean and
because of our school
like in the younger grades I might have
played a few reps but we weren't in
those positions so it was hard for any
coach to come to third division and
um you know we had some 23 year old
uncles playing as well so
um it was hard and I just felt like
some of my mates that went to town
schools and they played for repsides I
felt oh I could use them as a bit of a
reference there they've made these teams
I might be able to have a crack as well
and so there was a wee bit of like chip
on my shoulder having come from poridor
and and wanting to give it a real crack
and when you made that New Zealand 19s
team did you feel like you're good
enough no no like that was a good thing
I went in there going oh man what a buzz
but
the formula since then has always been
the same for me just working hard and
you know even if you're in the team for
a longer period and the good thing is I
never really had enough Talent so you're
forced to work but it's actually the way
you find out what you're about you know
so you know I feel like now sometimes
Talent especially when it's congested
and in top schools or top areas and
people can rely on that and and it
serves you for a long period but if you
haven't had tests or multiple tests you
don't have should have resilience you
don't have a it's not resilience you
just you've never been
you know run around before you're
tackled you just used to run through
everyone and if you never had that it's
um you know and then that comes late or
you avoid that
you get a little bit older and it's like
man yeah
it's gonna hit you at some point yeah
yeah yeah so um
it's interesting and then you obviously
went into the Wellington lines at a
pretty young age too
um pretty intimidating environment was
it
um not not really like Peter latini
um Allah used to pick me up so this was
funny he was an all black midfielder at
the time and he was at Northern porirua
and I obviously no car to get to
training so he used to come and scoop me
up oh sure yeah it was it was cool and
looking back now I was like man you know
and they're going far up and then a
couple mornings my mum she's like oh can
I get a ride as well
in the back she's like I saw him in the
back and she's yawning to Allah um you
know you're like oh man what are you
doing
um you know next day it's Dad his mating
yeah another's driving people all over
what he's doing no but I think that was
cool because one you realized um yeah
he's the all black midfielder at the
time just signed for Wellington and and
the kind of person he was so you kind of
re you worked out pretty quick that man
you can still be
that guy you know and um some people you
know can or some people can't but Allah
was awesome so I kind of you know had a
I could work hard but also try and try
and be the best kind of person and how
long did it take before you go to crack
or your day burn at that level
um it's funny because like I was in the
like
um like in and around the squad you know
the academy back then it wasn't that big
so yeah you're lifting weights with like
Cully and Jonah and those guys all at
the gym yeah fire out
um it was good though though you know
they're all cool game you know in in my
eyes so real Superstar guys but again
just real nice nice men and
um I took a wee wall before I actually
got a game funny because Cully played
his last game and I played my first in
the final oh I first kept for Wellington
we played Auckland in the final and um
uh he he came off and he was like
standing ovation
every week five minutes
gonna get used to this
um so yeah that was the start of it I
think CJ was was in the squad at the
time and had been
drop for that game it's quite funny like
Chris Boyd had us both in his sheds like
you're gonna play to me and I was like
trust me buddy
you know what Siege is like he's like oh
man yeah I've been the squad all year
what did he do
um
I'm not sure we've probably got some
dreads
yeah now he was obviously a gun man as a
young player he was awesome strong could
do everything on the field and if he
could sort the hair up man
could have you know it could have been
great so were you mainly a fallback back
then did you go on yeah
I was just aware ever I think I was
Midfield cover at the time and yeah I
think it was more to give Kelly a
standing ovation
and then what was the stepchum there did
you make the Hurricanes the following
year uh no I didn't I I didn't so I was
like they're five minutes wasn't good
enough I couldn't do it in the fight
um yeah just kind of again just keep
working to get rips and kind of um
script for what I could in the next
couple of years hurricanes that I went
to New Zealand Sevens oh yeah so kind of
in that space we uh
you've got enough between uni a
scholarship and matches you know and
it's a kind of real digging are you
going to get over the line and become a
pro or not so New Zealand Sevens was
good loved it was it to the Commonwealth
yeah that was an 06.05
um was I was on the circuit yeah I think
yeah that was cool with my first sevens
game at Wellington at Westpac oh sure
packed and we won that comp and
um you know I was like man this is
awesome yeah and I loved it I read
sevens suited me again because I was
probably fit enough
um to keep going and enjoyed such as
coaching really hard but yeah I enjoyed
it and again I would have said a lot I'd
like to stand the sevens for a longer
period but
um yeah I think eventually started
cracking to the you know wider
hurricanes Etc so that Wellington sevens
was Next Level yeah back then uh yeah I
never um went as a um spectator oh true
so I think my first time was when I
played but it was awesome all right
shame that it's gone and no more sevens
in New Zealand real yeah yeah is there
no seven didn't it no oh no not even
Hamilton it's been cut yeah oh too many
V8s
so why did you go to
um The Wider squad over the sevens
now I was doing both oh yeah yeah so so
the the I think my first fully
contracted Euro six
um and I think the wider at that time
was enough wider an NPC was enough to
you know yeah keep you going and
um yeah I went to the wasn't playing
much I went to the Commonwealth Games in
o6 uh with a few boys had dropped out of
Super Rugby then kind of boost the team
and I think they were waiting for like
Duck Island and rocks and I turned up
you're here last year you got no speed
oh yeah because
how was it though it was awesome like we
had a good crew um Liam miss him and I'm
Corey Jane Linda silk I think my
surveillance
was that an Aussie yeah oh yeah yeah it
was cool we're in a great tournament and
to be in the village and it's you feel
like you're part of something bigger we
sometimes rugby you know we were bubbled
and yeah so it's cool you know watching
the different athletes and supporting
some of the others yeah awesome right in
the gold medal yeah it was cool I've
lost it since unfortunately
um I think I I huckered it off went too
hard in the first time and um it fell
off and I was running around giving it
that one and another one then we're
huckering again and they kept pointing
at me and I was pointing at them but
they're saying that my middle had fallen
so I went and found it
um but again I've lost it again
yeah it could have been could well have
been
but I've never been one for um you know
no disrespect to Awards Etc but I've
never really been one to
um especially as a player to hang Awards
because whereas now as a coach I
probably would I'd hang a team Jews
because it feels like you're part of a
sometimes there's a player individual
stuff is you know hanging that around
the house and what what's my wife
hanging um you know it's it's more than
kind of you know one
One winner in the house yeah yeah but I
wouldn't mind finding it though
let's track it down but then um
obviously when you go after that you go
back to the hurricanes and this is when
you become a bit more of a regular
player a bit more of a starter yeah
again we're great midfielders obviously
snakey and when I first joined
tunnelottu we had abundant of
midfielders so it's funny I started as a
10. I had a long kick yeah you know it's
in rugby league park as you know well
when they're Northwest that he comes and
the coaches are real helpful with your
kicking by like sitting in the coach's
office and just watching Chris Boyd did
that to me
that that many times oh yeah so the
kicking uh I started as a 10 and then
ended up finishing as a wing true which
is funny so just because there's so much
talent in the Midfield yeah and you know
like we're recruiting uh there for a
time yeah came Jimmy gotworth you know
you're with the Midfield was stacked CJ
was the full at full back
so you're with heated Talent at the time
so just again where I could get a game
so how did you go from this like utility
guy who's playing everywhere little bits
of minutes to becoming an all black
um I I feel like at the time the skill
set had changed for kind of midfielder
Wingers the South Africans were bombing
everyone like kicking bombs and they
went away from like um city and the ball
carrying Wingers and maybe like cooks
and I was at Guilford CJ the Wingers who
could slash middies they could do a few
different things yeah
um that's interesting I don't know so I
don't I used to drop High balls all the
time so
when I caught them I had a half decent
Kickback so that might be might be right
why oh it's tough when they say oh he
picked you for your high but wasn't deep
down you're like man I'm not even good
at it I thought you're talking about the
highball kicks
oh you want me to catch them as well so
did you
so did your selection come out of the
blue or like how do you find out uh no
I've been in the New Zealand like
Juniors or a well yeah I was Captain of
that team
um so you knew it was coming no it
didn't um it's funny I cool story Fiji
saw John KU when he was coaching up
Japan at the time oh yeah and he just
balled me up like by the reception
and just said oh do you want to be an
all black and I was like oh
yeah and he's like do you know what you
need to do to be an all black I was like
no it's like do you know who to ring and
I was like yeah anyway
um just called got the info and then
they had some injuries so this it sounds
like it's called her who do you call I
think was Smithy at the time sure but
again like because Fozzie was our coach
um Colin Cooper uh they were already in
comms around what we needed yeah
um but it's smart you know like if you
want to get a job ask what they want you
to do on the job yeah it's just
interesting it bold me up but but yeah
thankful for for JK to for doing that
and then I actually joined them the next
week in Wellington at Camp what a phone
call yeah what did you say on it
give us a script yeah no
nah I can't remember
um but yeah I just went to Wellington
they had a few concussions and
um yeah I think they were they hadn't
had many wins at the time as well but it
was cool and that was super nervous you
know rolling to camp and
it's one of those ones where you're kind
of like
yeah yeah how do I sit
is this seat at the back of the bus all
good to sit here on the First on I just
got it early
[Laughter]
I can't believe the phone call you just
talked to your answer yes
it was mine and I don't even think I
spoke to Smoothie like posts that we you
know would because I was I was kind of
in the the group but it was yeah I might
have gone through fuzzy yes yeah
and then when you made it um obviously
was the expectation on you to do
anything bring anything to the group
yeah
well first they told me to leave my um
vibrant five fingers it's not a sponsor
but I tore my um tiny calf
um because I was wearing these like toe
shoes oh yeah in in respect to the
people who were
so shoes
and we tore my calf so I missed the
championship or the ability to be
selected for the championship and then a
hard-running beaver Donald played 12.
um just vicious on the down oh that was
going to be your and Hamilton yeah I
think so yeah and then didn't start
until the India tour so I had to get
right by the end of your tour why were
you wearing the calf [ __ ] like um five a
guy just gave all these free ones to the
the all books and I don't think the boys
were keen and I was just like man
six months of Christmas wrapped these
under you know
and but I Overworld them and the first
time I didn't wear them bang so I know
the all books was good I I got to Camp
one of the things they do into your toy
gun go and meet the coaches and talk
about like your goals for the tour and
their thoughts on you and why you're in
the team Etc and yeah it's really funny
like sitting with Ted and shagging
smithian she's like oh you're gonna be
great on tour and I said oh yeah thanks
dude he's like you sing You Dance you
play the guitar and I was like
[Laughter]
the heritage
it's like man went back I think CJ might
have been my roommate and he's like what
what'd you say I told him he's like
crazy I'm laughing
um guitar lessons straight away
he would have been the worst person to
get out of it too every post game he was
like Jack he wants to I've got a guitar
he's gonna and being you know like the
old school environment guitar is awesome
yeah sing song over an iPod any day yeah
just not from me
did you have to do it did you back it up
I reckon I led um Stand By Me which was
my kind of go-to
um I just let it hard and then faded you
know yeah you've got to time it once
people have had enough drinks there yeah
they're just going to roll with it if
you go too early
but you said you're at your dance so
would you get up and just dance in front
of the group or how would that work when
you say you could entertain by dancing
what the boys just watch you dance
[Laughter]
[Music]
no no I enjoy it dancing when you go out
you know yeah cut a few shapes um but
not at the front of the team New Zealand
20s or 21s I think was like Luke
McAllister pretty whippy with this
massive dance battle at the World Cup I
can't remember what it was like where we
were like taking on these other guys
yeah
um yeah I don't know if I was crumping
but and I wouldn't like to see the
footage
but he's a good dancer is he yeah he
moves well sure yep what sort of dancing
do you do when you say dancing is it
cramping or is it what sort of dancing
salsa no just the no just express
yourself eh yeah yeah just move with the
music yeah
laughs
just just try your best as well
I try to win more one Christmas and the
big like uh Swindle not pulps I think
that pulps but pulps for men yeah we're
in and I was trying to like um when one
I keep whacking I reckon I've done both
my meniscus
and the Clapping died down I was like oh
I'm not tucking it under enough
so yeah those sort of moves yeah yeah
yeah
that's actually I don't know if I went
to Hamilton the the other day the um
stage show in Melbourne awesome and it's
one of those things we watch it it's a
hip-hop r b station just because of what
the kids as well at home you're just
dancing to everything so yeah I don't
know it's probably
again it's not serious but yeah
do you reckon you could have gone down
that route as a pro dancer a pro dancer
uh
nah I don't think so because again it's
like it's choreographer yeah yeah
no I just want to do you do you yeah
yeah yeah
so then you get over to
um the India tour with the OLX you're
singing you're dancing how did the how
did the footy go it was all right we
it's interesting like first time in it
you're not that brave and you're real
you know it's like boys here in
preseason you're super tense you don't
want to make a mistake so that's you
know I enjoyed the tour and
came back to New Zealand still went
straight to the Japan post that tour why
was that
um I at the time I think we're coming
into the 11 World Cup and like Sunny was
have resigned and
snaky skunks caucus is like a probably
the best midfielders we've had in one
period And I
was a wee bit older too and I took me a
while to get into the All Blacks in my
mind how old were you I think I might
have been 25 true it's not that old yeah
but when you think of it you're kind of
like
um anyway I left went to Japan and had
18 months there and now then I came back
and I managed to get back in the team
again and probably that second round I
felt more comfortable you know and which
just goes to show a lot of it is mental
you know what you think you yourself in
that moment whereas
um near post Japan I just played freely
enjoyed it was down the Highlanders new
club in um yeah the rugby was
a lot easier because I was easier on
myself in terms of my head game it's a
mess of learning I wish I had it earlier
in my career but
um I wouldn't change it that you know
having always having a fight for minutes
and positions Etc I didn't really have
the luxury of relaxing in a lot of ways
I was always trying to learn and you
know goal kicker it's like special teams
just like yeah I'm on every special team
goal kicker guitar player like
spokesman speechmen every sponsors gig
and
yeah but when I came back you know I
just I enjoyed the footy and played a
lot better so why did you go to the
Landers obviously you're a Wellington
boy Keynes Kane's Legend yeah I think at
the time
you know I thought about it I was home
and Jamie Joseph who coached me at
Wellington I played wellville was it was
at the hollanders yeah and I didn't I
think he was new so he was recruiting
all right I was home on a break and he
just gave me the big
you know the big pull the tissue down
and how you going bro and when you get
that one you're like oh
and he's like it's in your contract now
you know and you've got to sign it now
you're like oh
but I was home and I was keen and yeah
um it was good it was it was different
it was fresh under the roof so I really
enjoyed my time down there
um yeah you weren't part of that bad
culture clean out at the canes that
wasn't you nah and I wasn't part of the
it's gonna sound funny and I wasn't part
of the Highlanders one one to 37 or
something like
laughs
that wasn't me man
now I I loved it down there I actually
I played the Highlanders that first year
enjoyed it and then I had a shoulder
Recon after the India tour the next year
and didn't play the next I played
probably three games at the end of the
year of the Year where we lost a lot of
games so that was hard in a way because
you're in a sling and you know it's hard
to play a guitar and a sling so I
couldn't get on the field and
um
so it was it was a tough year yeah
because it was good coaches and good
players
um and we were just losing games and and
that tension built
um
and then they made a documentary about
it I'm joking
see in January Bender om7 that was the
year eh when you guys were oh and said
yeah yeah
true and you had the stack team
you even even I've had on who's been in
that year always speaks about how
stacked that team was even was coming in
like yourself and just to confirm I was
injured for the seven first games
did you come back I played the last
couple oh that's true so you're the
difference
and now I played the last couple in
South Africa yeah and did you have kids
at this stage was your wife moving
around with you yeah yeah we had um two
when we got to Dunedin oh yeah and then
um we got back to Japan and just started
I'm going for it you know so how many
more years did you go to Japan for
um I reckon another six true so why'd
you leave the Landers that year
um again look I'd come home for that
period yeah I've been been away for two
came home for two
and then at the time they said something
like I was backstabbing a lot of the
boys and they wanted
oh Jesus here we go no
um again I felt when I came home to
start with yeah would have been for a
short period just to have that crack and
that taste of well yeah it's a bit of a
lie now because to have that last crack
at Super yeah I went to Japan and then I
had three years with the rebels so I I
try to come back to uh the hot the
Highlanders again but I hadn't played
the 80 caps that you needed to oh really
yeah Andy also Andy was doing Kobe and
Crusaders oh yeah and what were you on I
was 78 and they would have really yeah
the funny thing was
uh if I had assigned the Highlanders I
would have played enough to get me over
to then go back and forth yeah
um but yeah I mean they're probably
trying to set a some kind of rule that
is it was a joke I think that's what it
was
kept it two before yours yeah
right that's crazy but you obviously
love Japan yeah to spend that much time
over there family love that yeah yeah we
um we really enjoyed it we had a great
spot where we were we're you know great
group of foreigners
um you need that especially for you know
the wives and partners the kids to be
able to connect
because you it can be isolating in a lot
of ways if you set it up it's the
opposite you get really connected with I
was there with Colin Burke and Mike
broadhurst Tim Nano Williams Oh yes
Robbie Robinson Mata came up for Aston
uh Rory Kinney Kenny Lowell sure there's
heaps of us Holly T Paul and we just had
a good group there we like off the field
would connect the family's all got on
and then when we got to work as a
collective we were like man we gotta put
it in here I think sometimes in Japan
can go the opposite some
foreigners don't get on well and
um yeah but we love to you know loved
our club there at Rico and yeah I
appreciate that time and how'd you find
the footy yeah it got better like when I
first arrived Stephen Larkin was there
he was a player
um so it was cool you know he was a
probably you know a bit of a
revolutionary kind of guy with the
brumbies in those early days and to
watch Bernie and to get some arm was
cool
um I think the footy got better and
better yeah I still think it's getting
better up there
um you know sometimes you're like man
what are you doing but the first few
years you're really just ripping in you
know it's new so it's fruition
um yeah a man with all the ideas like
you have was it hard for you to not try
and put too much on these guys or try
and change too much yeah yeah I'm more
for the coaching yeah like depending on
what level of Coach you've got there at
the time you're kind of trying to
support them the best way you can and
and I think the good ones would take on
as much info as you could
um being that you you come from Super
and some guys Internationals like James
Haskell was there as well oh yeah um and
we'd all try and chip in um and
sometimes it could get frustrating when
I guess the coach wouldn't embrace it as
much whereas here like you know we bring
in all the info and try and get the best
and as opposed to I feel particularly at
times maybe the coach were feeling like
the the Japanese might think they're not
doing their own thing I'm not sure but
now you know we loved it up there so did
you play Landers with Haskell and then
go to Japan with her uh we the other way
around oh it's Japan first and then the
land is here oh yeah so you must have
been there uh at the big party that time
I wasn't no oh no you're the one you
went home with the two who didn't go I
didn't get invited because um something
about that no no I wasn't it yeah
probably I went to the next day which
was cool
um now hesky's he's a he's a full-on
dude and yeah um he was kind of like our
stepson almost like me you Dupree in
Japan oh yeah it's always over my wife's
a good cook so he's always like yeah you
know
um he's got good manners polite English
boy in here yeah it was funny yo funny
old sit up with him like lima dunked an
egg on his head and then Kate jumped
over the fire and Thompson came off the
top rope but um
hesk is good at because
like the next day with a Cordy and he
just stood up and explained the whole
thing yeah and I think for a lot of
kiwis I kind of like oh well he just
gets old yeah yeah as opposed to holding
any kind of a few boys came in and yeah
you know
but it was cool yeah I loved it it
really uh enjoyed playing with him he's
a full-on dude yeah he's got some energy
man
um he just had a baby so be interesting
to see that slows him down surely yeah
wait till he gets to six yeah yeah yeah
and then you you mentioned at the end of
your time at Japan instead of coming
back you tried to come back to Landers
but you end up over at the rebels yeah
how did that one how did that one work
out um I kind of remember how I think
maybe Scott fusela might have been there
already oh yeah I can't remember the
initial conversations but went there
Tony mcgahn awesome like arrived
because when I was going back and forth
from Japan like some days I'd arrive on
Captain's run before the kickoff of the
first game and just roll out like I
started the Landers because the Chiefs
had one Captain's run true
um so it shows like
what preseason
um yeah and the same with uh the rebels
just met them Tony mcgahn really enjoyed
his coaching months the head coach
full-on dude but again different so
swears every second word but yeah taught
me plenty about footy ripped into their
loved Melbourne that was different I
just been up there last week with the
storm and when I rolled in I was like
man how do we come here with three kids
some suitcases and do that back and
forth three years yeah I wouldn't do it
again were you moving back and forth
yeah just suitcases yeah far out so that
was kind of we'll just Bowl up yeah
pre-season play then leave
um crazy it was good kept you fresh and
Melbourne's an unreal City tough on the
wife and kids though yeah
she was yeah I think she was now we
again
um the Melbourne part was a good break
for us we'd had a wee bit of time in
Japan yeah so go there the kids were at
school yeah
um you're I think we spin out whole
wages on food but it was a fresh nut in
Japan and probably allowed us to stay so
long in Japan and you get to play Super
again which is you know if you still
feel like you can I think you should and
with your kids at school age then so
without jumping back and forth with a
full Japanese Advanced Australia Fair
yeah for Aussie skull they weren't at
school in Japan we homeschooled them oh
okay um so we try to keep them on the
same curriculum because we're moving so
much yeah they went to school Melbourne
and you know like interesting yeah cool
we went to that my wife's from the Cook
Islands in
we got then my daughter was like are we
Japanese or are we Australian oh man
[Laughter]
um so it was interesting you know to
bring them home and yeah since coming
back home they've just embraced
you know New Zealand
um they love Kapa Haka yeah we can spoil
all the stuff that they've potentially
missed I I looked at my son I was like
man I reckon this guy's six months away
from just living on an iPad oh yeah when
we're away yeah although there were Jiu
Jitsu Rock Climbing heaps and you just
he hadn't had their social stuff yeah
now he's in you know now he's loving it
he's 14 vaping the whole thing
he's not
uh and how was uh how was the footy over
the head of the Aussie footy the style
of footy compare good learnings like I I
honestly think the Aussies are tougher
yeah I think well especially the the
Melbourne because we didn't have the
talent so it was like match in men
running hard Sean McMahon running hard
like
and potentially because we train next to
the storm we're trying to run harder
than them
um but they are the gritty and they're
tough and fit
um so I was cool from a again learning a
different style of coaching and and
watching where you can push
um
push players too to get the most out of
them especially in those kind of no
Talent areas and
um I love the I love the footy up there
we had a we had a good good group we
were probably just missed their
theirabouts
um on a lot of games but it was become
the depth in the end and a group like
that if you lose a few in Key spots then
you really start to bleed and whereas if
you can keep your your 15 fresh you'd
probably be you go right is that what
you'd say the massive differences
between the carry sides and the Aussie
sites obviously played they've coached
both sides of the Tasman so was that
would that be the biggest difference
that you've noticed that depth uh dip
yep definitely depth um the other thing
you know like in a on a play style as
well
um you know we can
we've probably got more Flair and
ability to be able to play like they've
probably changed the DNA of especially
the wallabies
um of the the group but I think we again
that in deep down that's still that that
tough
um you know grindy kind of footy short
passing which has actually come back in
a lot of short passing Loops return ball
stuff but yeah that would definitely be
a different big difference and then how
hard they train holy maybe that's why
they haven't got the depth in Maryland
[Laughter]
so why did you have to retire and then
what what was the what was the reason
was it injury or just decision no it was
decision you know I got
probably we were frustrated with I felt
at the time and I'd felt for a while
that
I thought I could do more coaching
especially in Japan and the level I was
um and when you make that decision
internally I think your body starts to
kind of
you know you start going leading that
way so the final contracts I was on like
player coach and then coach
um gigs which allowed me to kind of
um
yeah to do a bit more coaching and I I
like to think I'd probably help the team
more especially in those last year's
than I could as a player and yeah and
it's kind of got me on the coaching uh
did you always want to coach was that
like a plan from a young age or no it
wasn't
um well like I've always enjoyed the
game and and probably part of not having
a lot of talent is you've got to
understand like where the shortcuts are
yeah and you can do that if you study
the game more so by studying the game
and having a passion for that part it's
you're doing that a lot as a coach
anyway so understanding you realize
that's not for everyone like people are
like men no thanks yeah
um but yeah I was doing that for a while
so it kind of made a lot of sense to
have a have a go
and have you found it obviously look at
look at the success you've brought to
every team you've been involved with
them now obviously very good I've
witnessed it firsthand your world class
but have you found um coaching uh it's
it's been challenging I think having
good people and good structures
definitely help
um what I mean by that is having
kind of um leaders and support staff
that allow you to be yourself
um you know from a technical perspective
you're trying to work out what your
style might be but as a person if you if
you're allowed to be who you who you are
well you can just rip in and that's a
big part from Ray
um down here where first met him he's
just like oh it's quite funny he called
and he's like oh it's razor and I was
like I've Got a Friend honoree I was a
shoe honoree
there's a shoe race off with Ray Sarah
he's like no it's a razor
and he's like Scott Robinson oh hey man
uh who you after like I think he's like
looking for a player I knew my playing
then Dave's been done he's like oh I
think you've thought about coaching I
was like I have now you know came down
but the thing with Ray's big on had you
not coached before no I was in Japan
coaching oh true and then I died but you
hadn't done anything here oh yeah yeah
yeah and he was
um he just learned like first thing talk
about
where I am where I'm from and my
background and obviously the footy stuff
to understand but probably I'm doing a
wee bit of Jiu Jitsu and and being proud
and my maoritanga is something that he
was like just encouraged me to bring
that so
I think that's been awesome I can come
to meetings and just
it doesn't feel like 2022 Maori like I'm
just just doing it as I normally would
at home and that feels really natural to
me and when I'm in that space then I can
do the learning so if I feel like I'm
trying to be what I feel like a coach
should be yeah you know I probably have
more white here clipboard glasses so
that's been cool yeah so when did what
speak about your today Journey like was
that from a young age as well and have
you always spoken it are you fluent yeah
yeah that's um fluent enough
um yeah like we grew up learning we were
in um it wasn't could a cope upper at
the time but because takawang or an
intermediate between or bilingual yeah
and we're great teachers and there's a
good movement at the time we're lucky
also saying Louis end up
um cutting a model pool
um we had really good teachers
that were they were all like really keen
and so my father hadn't learned both my
parents and Maori and but mum went to
school to learn
um my grandfather her uh her father was
in all black half-back and he he was
mildly and was on his way to
um South Africa for the All Blacks in
the 50s and he got turned around in
Sydney
um because he was Maori true so I don't
know whether that that spurred her to to
go and learn you know feeling a bit
guttered that happened to the old man
and and that was 1950s multi-wear he
wasn't speaking and ripping poo Gunners
and stuff on the boat like so it's kind
of like whoa if you think about it
I think it's like an r word but um so I
don't know we were lucky until we we
learned it in kabak and we it was just
something that we always did and um yeah
it's just cool in these environments to
to have um the support to just embrace
it and and do what you would you do at
home anyway that is Cohen and talk to me
about your plans like obviously you're
into your third year here with the
Crusaders uh Wellington coaching jobs up
for grabs next year what are you
thinking are you looking to potentially
take that or where do you see your
coaching going
yeah
I'm really enjoying it here I love the
learning I love um the pressure
um of trying to repeat and get bit every
day
um the pressure being you know having
one to win again and go better I love
that um the support and the environment
is great uh again I'm from from
Wellington so I'm my whanau's still
there we both probably Door kids so
um and had success this year with
Wellington so it's a challenging one to
to work out where to be this New Zealand
Maori team as well that
um I'd love to be a part of one day for
obvious reasons
um yeah so I'm kind of in
making the few decisions at the moment
and have a good chance over Christmas to
reflect on the year and then also plan
next steps you know you've got to think
about the big picture being
um you know a bit of an ice he's been
with we've been together now 22 years
and like
that's a lot of support and I need to
make sure it's genuine when I talk to
like to say do you want me to keep doing
this or do you want me to be an actor
I can do it and I can bring in more two
choices here
so you know we can make sure that we
consider everything
um you know it's final first and making
sure they're in the best position my
um old man
um
yep he's oh he's
sorry no it's good
um
yeah
we should make decisions for the best
um for our family yo man
he was a center he reckons there's books
into back in the day he reckons well
that people tell me but he's
um he's been cooked for a while so
one of the decisions we came back to
Japan was just be closer to home
um yeah and making good decisions for
our kids like these these years and
moments with
grandparents and and for us with my wife
and I with our parents are important and
we need to make sure we have we
definitely do spend so much time with
them so that's important as well
um but he also gets you know he knows
that them he's not like I don't see you
man he loves it that I'm down here and
ripping into the footy and and he sees
how happy I am because I love the work
and
um yeah so
the next next little period will be
interesting but we'll try and make sure
that um
yeah we can try and get the best of of
most of it thinking of um the big
picture it's definitely the hardest part
about coaching for me it's not about me
I mean it's it's a fun job I love it
love every day but
um the other side of it hey what your
partner or
um whoever it is has to go through with
looking after the rest of family moving
around chasing chasing the dreams and
sacrificing all this stuff for you to do
your job which I know like me personally
I did it as a player so then to try and
now do it as a coach it seems a little
bit selfish so yeah
um it is I feel like it's a sort of a
job without kids or a partner I feel
like but if you've got that support like
you obviously do
um must be awesome to have that packing
it is it is and it is a saying you need
to be really considerate when we talk
about
um the future that I'm it's not like I'm
doing rugby 100 and then let's make some
decisions it's like if if we're going to
do something else we'll do it we'll make
sure that it's we know we're genuine
we're going to love it
um but as you see making sure it's it's
not that Rugby's Trump and everything
yeah again kind of thing and then
obvious kids in middle I get frustrated
when I bring the whistle home and just
start demanding
the mining things around the house The
Lawns and the washing and that so
um it's just a habit you know yeah
if you weren't um coaching what would
you be doing you reckon um I'd be
coaching some
um you know probably in in the almori
space Health Fitness
um holder in some form it's a passion
any way I get to do it
my daily job and I learned plenty to
then do it outside of footy yeah not
again it's from where I've been brought
up and um
I just feel and rugby and professional
environments there's so much good stuff
that you can kind of share it twice in
here and then you're you're out there in
the community sharing it because if you
if you don't get into these places for
whatever reason
um it doesn't mean you should have to
miss out so like yeah if I wasn't 40 I'd
be in
still in some form of coaching
leadership and sharing that's what I'm
passionate about so um
I love it well as always we have gone to
our Instagram for some questions and the
lad you are you've had plenty come in
and I I sort of missed it during the um
as we're going through it but the most
of the questions were about this magical
moment
um Highlanders versus the Crusaders I
think you're at 13 at some magical
offload some people call it the greatest
pass in Super Rugby history talk me
through it
yeah
um I think obviously I was probably the
last couple games of the season
and was this that year that the Owen
seven year like I can't remember it
might have been it might have been
because I was like I was playing with
one arm you know
um so I had a shoulder Recon and Jamie
brought me back early so um that's the
first part I was in the Jamar brace
um and then when I um push Ryan cruddy
off um the All Blacks
no just I think by the end of my career
like you do that at touch and you get
around the back or over the top whatever
and
um it's a good learning point as well
that so you can do things on the field
you know as long as you practice it and
you know what you're doing yeah just
I've always thought like if you bring
the board of the line that way they can
get in between the paths whereas if you
put it around your back if you're
accurate enough you can dig in and force
that guy to turn so yeah it was more
yeah
it was more just yeah going for it
really yeah and I would say the same
thing to kids now like if you have that
skill
and you're getting rips on it you know
pull it out because yeah yeah so how
come we didn't see more of it
well as I said like I started my career
man I was yeah you're not getting on the
field for five minutes and going around
the back like that
you're gonna be back at Club rugby real
quick
and you get on for five minutes and then
you talk make your tackles think of any
penalties and next week you get seven
minutes that's why it didn't happen
earlier
oh it's good stuff okay next man ask him
about the story of how he tackled Richie
McCourt training
this for you it'll be from CJ probably
yeah I don't know like we had this live
kind of clean out drill yeah and um yeah
this is
this is probably more what is it grav
McGraw than Jujitsu but like he was over
the ball yeah I kind of came on an angle
and tried to just get like get a double
um back leg or just tip him yeah and uh
I got him somewhere else and he just
like
Felton and pretty much pop straight off
um wait got us nuts nah
now accidentally uh
well as my hand was going around to get
it's back
it's like a quick jab and he just
spooked him like a cat on the roof
I haven't actually taught that
yeah
I'll leave that to the invitation yeah
but I haven't bought that clean up
technique in you
the coaching starts going south now I'll
be bringing those ones in for cat on the
roof clean out
oh no wonder um when he was on the other
day
you're way down the back he could look
me in the eye sorry
oh that's good okay next round why did
he hang upside down on this bunk bed oh
man
is this uh this is from my brother yeah
I can't explain that one because uh he
this is my brother Jacob he was doing it
first and
um people thought we were twins when we
were younger
um because he was the same size yeah
they used to give us the number one
haircut like all the time yeah
um so now he uh he invented it the
upside down hang and
if I just see I followed his lead to
what did it do
no it's just good for your strength yeah
oh that's a good Christian Jake
okay Christmas
I don't quite get it but um next one
does he still use orange is this Spritz
as his facial routine and is that why
he's aged so well that's Dwayne Sweeney
yeah it is is he still have two Snickers
bars a week yes
um oh man I gave up on the orange Spritz
I had probably the worst game of rugby
ever played first fire for New Zealand
Maori and was goal kicking dancer Brioni
was the opposition 10 and I was just
spraying them there's probably one from
seven
we lost the game and um
yeah I gave up the orange Spritz so what
was that what is it vitamin C oh yeah
face spray like I was just being real
super healthy that year I've been um to
these coaching courses and I was using
everything and that like under the sun
yeah including the Spritz and then I had
a shocking game and
you haven't used it since
you have aged quite well though you put
it down to your what facial routines or
no no no no no
um
but I did see Big B to Marty Williams I
reckon he's dying us here early oh true
sorry B
um let's throw on him under the bus
I'm just thinking yeah it might just be
um might be jet black
I went great pretty early yes I always
wear a hat
but you're someone from memory this is
just a story that I heard someone who
always spent a lot of money or you
invested in yourself as a rugby player
yeah like when you reflect back on it it
actually makes a lot of sense because
um you know if you get one more year
out of it and depending you know like
the back end of your season especially
if you're overseas it's going to pay
itself off um
so making sure you're you're trying to
get the best out of your career because
with footy it is it comes and goes
really fast so getting some support and
yeah
it's been great for a lot of reasons
um still catch up with a lot of those
guys and still use a lot of the the
techniques
um that was taught back back then and
it's been well worth the investment mate
because it makes so much sense he said
all the time these young kids just
expect everything to be put on a plate
but
um the biggest investment as a
professional rugby player is obviously
yourself so whatever you need to do
whether it's all those little things
what what little things were you doing
like give us an example of some of those
so some of them were like courses
outside of footy oh yeah going away like
a two-day course around like Peak
Performance and oh yeah and learning
some Strat I remember coming back from
them and you're just like get on cloud
nine and yeah you're at work scrubbing
the toilet actually yeah you know like
you're buying people lunch and you're
just loving life and
but it's a really reflecting back being
able to be right in that moment and
giving everything to that moment because
of this you know I remember we're
testing
um like phosphate decrement and stuff
post
would have been the same week after I've
just come off this course and I was just
loving it oh man how good's statistic we
get to know where we are and if we're
not where we need to be like
we get a marker you know yeah we could
have avoided this and everyone's like
bro shut up
you're trying to get we'll bring your
positive yeah yes I was um
but it's again it's well worth it and to
realize that that's a mindset as well
you can get to that place
um it's not for everyone but um yeah I
definitely enjoyed it I'm sure and
especially with around goal setting if
you can get you know [ __ ] goals when
you're in that place you'll be surprised
at you know what you'll reach for um
so yeah I definitely recommend working
on your mental game you know you think
of how much of it we do
deliberately isn't there's not a major
part compared to everything else if you
get that part right it can make a
massive difference 100
like that took a bit of a detour off the
um orange zest but hell of an answer
um next one oh you'll know who this one
came from
I heard he can bout out lady in red can
he give us a re-endition
lady in red it's a good song I can't I
wouldn't do it justice although this is
a good setup really sound good eh um I
reckon if you're gonna hit it it's gonna
be on this nah even just there yeah I
almost missed that
um
yeah yeah I need to get back to singing
though
could you give us a little Stand By Me
or something
[Music]
when the night
that's our wind that's how they hit this
because I was like win the night and
then when it came on the computer was
like when the night
[Applause]
in the first steps and win the start
yeah and then um
and pray that people jumping
right I sort of I felt like I jumped in
shock or yeah amazement but yeah yeah do
you want to go again and do the whole
thing no that was good yeah it's just
snip it over here yeah a teaser yeah
you've got to pay for the concert
okay next one
um who's got to be the bad man so this
doesn't make much sense to me but
hopefully it does to you
yeah I'm trying to work out where this
is from
it's uh
yeah I like it Somebody's gotta be the
bad guy
I think you're one of the uh what's the
movie is it um drug movie or
so many yeah yeah um machine gun oh but
I yeah it's a cool line because it's
like
sometimes in what the person's saying by
being the bad man is
he's been disruptive you know like but
he's doing it for a reason someone's got
to do it sometimes standing around going
that's a person is like at least they do
it all the time and it's kind of going
again whereas Somebody's gotta be the
back so is that sort of a quote that you
live your life by no it's not not at all
um I'm the one saying hey somebody's got
to be the bad guy here it's not going to
be me
nah but sometimes yeah yeah more and
more I think
um in 2022 like
I want to get like real deep into
freedom of speech Etc but get in there
yeah yeah especially if it's for if the
intent is pure you know like the reason
you're doing it is this because that can
as it like now gets
sound bites headlines get it held and
then they're gone and turn into anything
so people don't say anything but
is it repressed yeah yeah somebody's got
to be the bad guy like it okay next one
hardest player you have to tackle it's a
manotahu in the league yeah yeah
yeah he played um we played New Zealand
a played wallabies yeah he was
midfielder then true
um super strong yeah and he's a bit like
Rene Ranger like Rangers he doesn't look
that big
um yeah Rock but he's like and then I
remember reading like a when someone
went back to uh the league read a
magazine as like the strongest guys in
the NRL in the gym oh yeah and he was
like power cleaning 120. oh I was like
man I wonder why I was trying to show
that to you yeah bring up on Chris Boyd
yeah Boyd he just got an article here
remember an oh wait went to monitor who
run through me all the hair right you
answered that so quick yeah you didn't
even have to think about it obviously
there's memories yeah
we've all got one yeah okay best
midfielder you had you got to play with
oh hard question oh yeah you played with
all of them
oh
I would have to say
Ma
um yeah like snakey obviously very
um close a snakey for different reasons
yeah I think um just the growth in
matters game though like this is a lot
of midfielders that have that power play
style
but not many evolve to have a long pass
long kick decision making at the highest
level like he's not doing this just in
super he's doing in test matches big
long
um kicking game so I think the evolution
of my own when where he finished
um
to where he started was was yeah I'm at
12 year at 13 is that the dream combo
um depends what years because you
wouldn't hit the ball like early days
you just have to clean the Rock
um maybe 15 because he loved them cut
out ah yeah yeah you hit too early yeah
15 on the bounce you better catch it too
[Music]
okay last question ask everyone this one
but best piece of advice you have for a
water LED listener
um
I think the best piece of advice
is
um
to know yourself and then to be yourself
so you know know what you stand for know
what's what's true for you and and yours
you know your whanau and whatever is in
your heart and then just be it
um
not trying to be anyone else's
whatever but take time to reflect on
what's important to you because
you know when we're I get a lot of time
here at the Cranford Oak Motel one 117 a
night free Milo you get a lot of time to
um you know reflect and yeah and think
about it so it's important when we're
working you're so much in it in the work
to take time to reflect and and um check
in on what's important to you because
that also changes you know that changes
over time so continuing to understand
yourself and then once you do then just
then just go and be it because
um if you're trying to be
something else for someone else I don't
it's never sustainable um yeah so I knew
it was going to be good but the best yet
love that advice and uh what a podcast
obviously
um I love to save some of the best
guests I can get for the last of the
season and well and truly delivered
heard a lot of good things about you
before I'm getting to meet you this year
but um been blown away with what a lad
you are I'm looking forward to working
with you this year and learned a lot off
you already so I'm excited for the year
ahead with you but
um appreciate you coming on the podcast
and giving up your time mate awesome
cheers Jimmy thanks a lot man you're a
lad
okay
[Applause]
[Music]